i guess if any of you guys want to come
back from something it's your lucky day
because jim nance just called it to the
program
he is one of our favorites one of my
favorites uh one of the uh the greats uh
jim nance here on the rich eisen show
how you doing jim
hello my friend it's good to be with you
right back at you i guess it's come back
week
right in front of you yeah unbelievable
sounds like it
sure sounds like it doesn't i mean last
night was
uh it was
it's still playing
on a loop
on in my head if that makes any sense
it's still so fresh i'm in augusta now
but
it just still feels so raw you know i
got barely any sleep and already been
out
to augusta national but i'm still
i have this every year on the immediate
hours and the transition from the
championship game
uh to augusta it's you just kind of
you've been so tethered to the
tournament for weeks you've called let's
see
six nine 12 games during the tournament
including the final four and you you
just i'm trying to like pull away from
it go over here to this little golf
thing
uh but
i know and then uh i mean what what what
did bill self say to that team at
halftime huh i mean you could see they
came out and and you know you guys
nailed it and you know rafter is talking
about going high low that's exactly what
they did you and grant hill were right
on top of it as well as it was unfolding
um what what what do you what do you
think bill self said to that team
last night jim i don't know i asked him
that uh on on the podium that was my
first question and he
he didn't have much to say about what
what what he told them i'm sure there
probably were a few things that
he didn't let in um but this was a
seasoned team and it had a recent
experience where they turned the switch
at halftime
in the elite eight against miami and
maybe there was a reminder there
it's interesting you think you've got
every single conceivable angle covered
and so much of this is just in my head
on recall but when we're at halftime
grant
just said if they come back a little bit
on carolina
the tar heel kids are going to have
could potentially have in their head
that baylor did this to them
so it might be a different approach in
the way that you come back
but
psychologically
the impact that oh my gosh
they're making a move we've been through
this and we let somebody come
from 25 down to ties and send it to
overtime ultimately prevailing but
they've been through that recently
and he foreshadowed it that wasn't on
the air we brought it up though when we
got it back after the ernie and the
halftime guys and i think there was a
little bit of that confluence carolina
had been on that side of it
relinquishing a big lead
and uh hope i've got my uh thank you man
i got my drive-through just came came to
me
life on the road
what's for lunch jim what do you got
what's for lunch well you know i landed
here
uh there was a little bit of weather but
we got up pretty quickly in new orleans
and i landed here at
3 15 yeah and
and then i got to the house and i was so
charged from the game i didn't unpack
and really go to bed till 5 this morning
so i just stopped at a good old
double d
pick up some coffee and some wake up
reps
[Laughter]
runs on run you know i ran out to the
course and then
they they blew the horns so i basically
got there and turned around
and uh now i just said hey
i'm gonna go have breakfast
a tradition unlike any other it's a
tradition
it's a new tradition unlike any other
gym
it is right i like that thank you it's
so true
so
good morning good night
jim nance here on the rich eisen show uh
before we do move on to obviously the uh
the big story at augusta national that's
gonna be right there in front of you
uh the the big story that you just put
in your rear view mirror being coach k's
final game as head coach of duke and
you and the rest of the team just
absolutely crushed it i mean uh you you
you got me right in the gut when i'm
sitting there watching and you're saying
is this the last time that he's just
huddled with his team and it it did turn
out to be that way what was that like
for you that perspective uh again you
you play so much of this stuff in
advance like an athlete tries to imagine
an envision
a a successful moment you know for us
brought in broadcasting we try to see
all these scenarios and wonder how we
would react because i don't script
things i have things floating around in
my head as far as where i might drop in
a piece of information but most of it is
feel and instincts
and the movie though that was going on
in my head as i followed duke first and
second weeks from greenville south
carolina to san francisco and this team
was evolving and getting
uh wiser and older
as as each game passed i kind of thought
this this just might be their their
moment i thought he might ride off into
the sunset with the championship but you
know i know sports doesn't always follow
those
those kind of preconceived notions and
uh i was well aware going into this
every one of those games that it could
be the last so
uh
it was
saturday night was epic i mean it's sure
to do what it did four weeks apart
uh it's um
it's inconceivable if you go back five
weeks ago and somebody would tell you
that hey caroline is not only gonna win
next week at cameron in coach case
send-off they're gonna beat him at the
final four and knock him out
uh yeah okay i believe that
but it was you know it was just raw
again
we just uh we're in the reactionary
business and
and that was a moment that uh
it was kind of hard to
to get your mind around that he was
walking off that floor for the last time
even though you knew it was coming
you know and and we make so much in our
business we hype there's hyperbole
there's exaggeration however you want to
put it
but you could make the case that was the
biggest rivalry game in any sport ever
because of the history between the two
the coach who's on um one of the benches
and the fact that it could be his last
game
you could really make that case i mean i
was talking about bears packers in the
nfc championship game or yankees red sox
and an alcs but neither of those
matchups involved somebody of coach k
stature
and um and potential you know final game
um you could make that case that was the
greatest rivalry set up ever make that
case
no question you can make the case i
think you can actually
close the case when it comes to college
basketball
and that will you transcend the college
game and try to take it to other sports
you know i'm sure people have their own
view of it but here's the way i look at
it
coach k
was the face of college basketball
since he won his first championship in
1991
of course he backed it up with a win the
next year which absolutely solidified
his stature in the sport and ever since
those teams of 91 92 and the leightoner
and hill and hurley group duke became
either you love him or hate him but
coach k was always the
the constant he was always the one that
was going to be there the players could
change but he's still there now how many
figures
in sport you and i cover them all
especially you
how many of them
could you say have been the face of
their sport
for the last 31 years now i've had this
it's not even a debate really i've had
this discussion with some people after i
first raised it take tiger woods here
this is the 25 year anniversary this
week of the win for the ages so i'll say
tigers unquestionably the face of golf
for the last 25 years now in and out of
that there are stretches where of course
he wasn't able to compete because of
injury etc
but will give tiger 25 years we'll give
brady 20 years even though peyton
manning you could argue was in there as
well as the face of the sport during a
lot of those years or you could say bill
belichick but you know you're going to
top that out at about 20 years
so where do you turn lebron
a long time but it's not 31 years kobe
it's not even you know 31 years
where do you turn and say anybody in the
american sports landscape has been the
face of their sport for 31 years and
there is no one other than mike
shashefsky so that was part of what it
was like saying goodbye to that this is
spanning generations
i feel so fortunate that you know noah
uh know him well and i got to call all
of his championships and i got to be
there for a lot of his highs and some of
his lows where they didn't win the title
or they didn't get to the championship
game like like this year but
college basketball will miss him i mean
he did
a lot of things to make uh the game
great and
uh
i i i gotta say he rallied this team
uh sure they were a two seat so they
weren't a cinderella they weren't an
eight seed like
north carolina but
i think a lot of people felt going into
the tournament after duke beat him and
then virginia attacked feed him in the
acc tournament i think a lot of people
thought they might be an early knockout
but they made it to the final four and
hats off i want to just say this before
i move past it hubert davis is going to
be
i think he's going to be a legendary
coach
and i i was just inspired by him being
around him this weekend having a chance
to have some face-to-face chats with him
and to hear the way he handles his team
and the way uh his philosophy works in
basketball and in life
uh i i know this is a hard one for the
tar heel nation to get over
i i i've been there on that side as a
fan
actually the same date april the 4th
1983
my beloved houston cougars there's no
team that means more to me than that
houston basketball program but we lost
on april 4th in 83 to north carolina
state and i'm going to tell you rich i'm
not over it
[Laughter]
i'm truly i'm not trying to embellish it
i am not over it i was there in the pit
in albuquerque and i know it was i know
it was 39 years ago but it still hurts
so um the thing is
after meeting with hubert
you know
he's got north carolina basketball
back to relevancy i mean it's hard to
imagine you could even say that
and i can just see they're going to be
great things to follow for him this one
stings today it's impossible to kind of
let go of it
uh because you had him down 16 you had
him 15 at halftime um and that's jarring
but he's going to do great things jim
nance here on the rich eisen show kind
enough to call in as he's on the fly
figuratively after flying from new
orleans to augusta national um where um
what a week we have all set up jim
um you you were the one who was i'm not
mistaken
you chatted with
tiger woods on live television on cbs at
the genesis invitational here in los
angeles on february 22nd
2021 the next day is when tiger had his
uh car accident and now here we are on
april 5th you and i talking and tiger
woods has appeared at the masters has
gone through several practice rounds he
said today as of right now looks like
i'm playing
i i'll just give it to you to put this
in in perspective jim nance
well you can imagine the whole world is
on
watch here we've got bad weather today
i'm not sure how much he would have been
out there anyway the course
is shut down there's even tornado
warnings in some of the neighboring
counties and uh it's coming down hard
but that's fine he this was not
something he was going to be out today
marching around if he was going to do
anything he might have played nine holes
like he did yesterday but uh yes i had
that sit down in the tower live at
riviera he was supposed to be there for
like 15 minutes he stayed for 45 or 50.
and then um a few weeks ago i went down
to florida
spent some time with him and tape an
interview that will air this weekend
at one o'clock eastern tiger win
tiger woods the win for the ages 25
years later it's an hour that leads into
the live final round broadcast and i
think it's fair to say because listen
i've known him since he was 16.
you're going to see a side of tiger
you've never seen before in that hour
and he's got
an air of nostalgia and he's very
open-hearted about that week
and
he was just outstanding and gracious and
i love that time with him and again i
was down in jupiter this was after the
genesis
and um i got no indication that what's
about to unfold here
was in the office i did not get a sense
that he was going to play here
how about that at all huh and i mean
honestly jim the last couple days i'm
seeing the photographs of his practice
rounds i had to make sure that these
weren't just photographs in the last two
three four five ten years because he
looks the same the swing's the same the
cro you know the pardon me the patrons
the gallery are it's the same it's
i can't believe this uh i'm i cannot
believe this like what what what what
even can i can't even compare what it
would be like if he's wearing red on
sunday and your you and uh sir nick
faldo are calling a possibility of this
happening because he said today
on your flight end i'm sure you saw the
sound bite can you think you can win it
he said i do and didn't
i was i was here you know like i said i
i i saw it uh he was asked
about that that he only
ever competes if he thinks he can win he
says uh i think i can
and it was interesting he did say this
uh
it's my concern is not about hitting the
ball i'm hitting the ball fine
it's about the walking
and it's a very hilly course
and extremely hilly and you hit a lot of
shots off a side hill lies so it's going
to be about the wear and tear and what
the powers of recovery are going to be
after you play one round and you go into
the next and of course it builds
and there's no rest when you're going 18
holes and hitting balls to warm up and
but it's the walking it's interesting he
had talked back at genesis and and that
was in mid-february
that
he didn't have the power to hit it out
there with today's guys he says you know
i'm like a weekend warrior i think is
how he described it
on our air and today though
uh he said hitting the ball is not my
concern
and he played with my man freddie
yesterday and justin thomas and fred
said that tiger his length he says
justin is not the longest guy
in golf but he's one of the longest
and he said
he's out there hitting it
at the same distance as justin on on on
every hole so
uh it's not so he he's got listen the
day i saw him we delayed when we were
going to meet
until 11 o'clock because he had a
workout and when i saw him
you know for the first time that day
i said man how you doing and he's he
said he had been up since i guess six
and he said he'd gone after it hard for
four hours
and uh you know he
they they cleaned up and
got dressed for the interview but
when i saw him i said well what you know
how fun was that he said not at all
none
none
you know i he the point is
i take take me for example man i need to
be working out for four hours in in over
the span of two weeks
you know he's doing this
he's doing this every day
he's doing four five hours and he hates
it i hate it for 20 minutes
okay
and he hates it for four hours
but
this guy is uh he's just different i
mean he is
this hunger to be great
uh
there's just no one like him and
i i listen he's not coming out here to
shoot a hundred you know he he's he's
not going to come out here and do
anything crazy had a couple people say
to me in new orleans geez do you think
he'll break 75
i said yeah yeah sure i do
tiger woods
he's not going to come out here and
shoot a million it's just not possible
well so i'm i'm excited i i i know he's
going to take all the attention off
everybody else in the field now he
doesn't have he's got one advantage
rich and that is he's not playing with
people having high expectations
so you know like if he makes the cut
people are going to look at this as a
monumental achievement and it is
tiger's gonna look at it like again i'm
here to win it but meantime i'm watching
all the press conferences today that are
going on in the clubhouse and folks we
have uh justin thomas with us justin
thanks for joining us okay first
question uh doug ferguson yeah justin
good to see you what about tiger
you know
nobody gets asked anything about
themselves you know bring in anybody
john rob's here world number one john
great to see you can you believe tiger's
playing this week and you know like they
love this
unless they win the tournament they're
not talking about them they won't love
that right but i think it frees up a lot
of people weirdly i think it gives them
a chance to go out and be under the
radar maybe rory mcilroy more than
anyone put that one under your hat and
think about that for a minute he could
come in here with all of this
because tiger he's not asking for it but
he has sucked the storyline all the way
alone onto him and meanwhile you got
mcilroy here with a chance at the career
grand slam if he wins it and it's been a
burden for him to be asked about this
for whatever it's been the last six
seven years since he's had a chance to
come in here and and get the last piece
of the puzzle well now he's coming in
here and saying he's not sitting down
and people are asking about the grand
slam they're asking about tiger so i i
think i think it frees them up
jim i cannot wait uh uh to listen to
your call and the rest of the crew and
um thanks again i i feel like i'm
holding you from your your your
hard-earned meal um so thank you
it's going well i can microwave it we're
all good
life i've got a couple of wake up wraps
here about to sink my teeth into
my first meal after the championship
game so uh i'm going to save her every
bite and uh i save her every second i'm
on with you pal
i love being with you
and i cherish it as well thank you for
the call jim have a great call this week
i will be thinking of you and uh and
that tower
you soaking in every last one of this
moment that i hope lasts till the last
hole on sunday that would be incredible
thank you
thanks for the call
loved it rich thanks right back at you
that's the the great gym dance here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here